[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde histoire et mémoire dans France
sur les traces de François Mauriac il a
traversé le siècle dernier comme un
prince de la littérature et à ciseler
l'actualité à travers son bloc-notes
décryptant l'histoire en train de se
faire celle de la France à travers lui
écrivain catholique tel il s'est prouvé
au dedans de son intimité mais avec la
liberté de publier des livres à daner
les saints selon l'expression de Roger
Martin du Gard venu d'un milieu
provincial conformiste bourgeois et
nationaliste il brilla dans le salon
littéraire de l'entre-deux-guerres
fréquenta les milieux nationalistes
avant d'exécrer la puanteur de l'extrême
droite xénophobe il publia même un
cahier noir de la collaboration
pétainiste dénonça le colonialisme en
témoin du Christ et devint le chantre
d'un gaullisme d'espérance auquel il se
montra d'une fidélité ardente son œuvre
littéraire est une mémoire vivante de
sentiment et d'événements portés par des
personnages tiraillés par des passions
extrêmes à travers François moriac c'est
bien de l'histoire et de la mémoire dans
France dont il sera question s'il
collectionna sa vie durant les
best-sellers les récompenses et les
honneurs un mépris aussi de l'extrême
droite il y avait chez François Mauriac
une forme de rébellion intime à l'égard
des siens une pudeur charnelle qui le
brûla jusqu'à l'épuisement selon son
fils Claude Mauriac et une créativité
littéraire a toujours fécondé entre
romans témoignage et poésie nous allons
découvrir cet arpenteur littéraire et
politique de la France passée
contemporaine aussi avec mes invités que
je vous présente Bernard Cazeneuve vous
êtes avocat ancien Premier ministre et
vous venez de consacrer un essai à
François Mauriac Florence delay vous
êtes écrivaine de l'Académie française
on dit bien écrivaine pour l'Académie
française personnellement je préfère le
neutre alors donc écrivain de l'Académie
française Raphaël Gaillard vous êtes
psychiatre et essayiste
[Musique]
alors avant de parler politique abordons
le Mauriac intime mystérieux scrutant
l'âme humaine la violence et la noirceur
des passions et dont vous dites Bernard
Cazeneuve dans votre livre que vous y
avez cherché le reflet de votre propre
existence
chercher quoi un éclaireur un mètre un
guide ou plus simplement
êtes-vous à la recherche d'un roman
familial
enfin je n'ai pas cherché dans le la
noirceur des âmes des personnages de
Mauriac le reflet de ma propre existence
et j'ai voulu dire que la lecture est
une occasion pour chacun comme
l'écriture d'ailleurs de livrer une
partie de soi-même et à chaque fois
qu'on lit un roman ou souvent étant
jeune lorsque je lisais un roman je
cherchais à éprouver des sensations des
émotions qui appartenaient à mon
intimité mon histoire
ce qui m'a frappé chez Mauriac c'est que
la lecture d'une autre vipère puis la
lecture des romans qui ont suivi m'a
fait entrer immédiatement dans dans
l'âge adulte alors même que je n'avais
que 9 ans et que j'étais dans les les
romans d'aventure de Jules Verne et les
belles illustrations de Gustave Doré
Raymond Aron avec coutume de dire qu'on
apprenait beaucoup
des gens illustrent quelquefois de qui
on était très différents et il apprenait
beaucoup plus
de Marx que de Tocqueville bien qui
une famille militante en creag à gauche
tel cas de mon père et de ma mère et
donc l'univers dans lequel j'ai vécu été
élevé est un univers absolument
différent de celui de Mauriac mais en
même temps lorsque je découvre Mauriac
ces personnages et puis plus tard le
bloc-notes je vois un écrivain qui a
comme il disait lui-même de son écriture
une pointe et qui à travers l'écriture à
travers la réflexion à travers la
construction complexe j'en conviens de
sa personnalité cherche à s'affranchir
en permanence de son propre milieu par
amour de la liberté lorsque celui qui
critiquait la religion espagnole de sa
mère c'est à dire une conception
traditionnelle liste fermée
conservatrice du catholicisme s'en prend
au clergé catholique français espagnol
bande de la guerre d'Espagne pour
défendre la République espagnole il fait
montre du d'une grande liberté de la
même manière lorsqu'il quitte le pour
L'Express pour défendre la cause de ceux
qui s'engagent contre la colonisation il
témoigne de la même liberté d'esprit et
j'ai aimé voir cette cette liberté
s'exercer cet homme s'affranchir de son
milieu pour dire finalement sur les
sujets les plus importants de son époque
quelle était la juste position et je
trouve qu'il y a là pour quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse à la politique il m'est
arrivé de m'y intéresser comme vous le
savez et il y a là quelque chose qui
ressemble un exercice de liberté de
libre conscience et de recherche de la
vérité Florence delay s'est habituel
comme ça de chercher
à travers l'itinéraire d'un écrivain
sa propre histoire
personnellement j'ai toujours aimé
copier alors c'est ce que j'ai enseigné
à mes étudiants que pour faire des
progrès il fallait copier les gens qu'on
admirait j'ai jamais copié Mauriac ni
essayer si vous avez copié qui qui j'ai
copié j'ai copié Marguerite de Navarre
qui était la sœur de François 1er j'ai
copié Ramon de Gomez cela Serna c'est
pas le sujet ce que j'aimerais dire tout
de suite c'est que je pense que on a du
mal avec les écrivains qu'admire vos
parents
pour Bernard Cazeneuve on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il soit
des modèles de lecteurs
la description que vous donnez de vos
débuts moi je suis née dans une
bibliothèque et Mauriac était l'écrivain
qui m'a très cher à mon père d'abord
était genre de lait et qu'il était
professeur de psychiatrie c'est ça mon
père était et
a été
élu comme Mauriac à l'Académie française
ce qui entre parenthèses
quand Bernard Cazeneuve évoque ses
lectures d'enfants il rappelle qu'il a
lu par hasard ne te vipère de Mauriac
à 9 ans
ce qui était épouvantable quand on y
sont mais il croyait qu'il s'agissait de
vrai vipères et il avait très peur des
vipères et cette histoire m'a frappé et
j'ai fait la coïncidence avec la
parution de notre vipères de Mauriac en
1932 et son élection à l'Académie
française en 33 et il a mis des vipères
sur son épée
bref il était un ami de mon père mon
père l'admirer au début il a été un
écrivain modèle pour mon père modèle
parce qu'ils sont prenaient à la
province au fond mon père était aussi un
provincial il était bâillonné
les provinciaux qui ont réussi à Paris
voilà c'est ça qui sont montés comme on
disait qu'on dit dans le Sud-Ouest ils
sont montés à Paris et là ils ont ils
ont franchi une étape mais
personnellement Mauriac n'a pas n'a pas
beaucoup compté
le bloc-notes à compter alors on va en
parler vous allez voir Raphaël Gaillard
à ce stade là vous c'est
c'est quel Madeleine littéraire qui a
déclenché quelque chose au départ chez
vous Mauriac ou quelqu'un d'autre
vous deux personnellement ce serait
probablement belzach mais ce que je
trouve
très important la danse que nous disons
de Mauriac ce n'est peut-être pas tant
Mauriac que le Mauriac de Bernard
cazeneu et ce chemin de Bernard
Cazeneuve vers Mauriac je trouve que
même dans l'écriture on a l'impression
de d'y trouver un écho à l'écriture de
Mauriac en y trouvant l'écriture de
Bernard Cazeneuve on y reconnaît son
éloquence mais aussi une autre écriture
qu'on écriture très tenue une très belle
écriture et cette impression que
en parlant de Mauriac dans cette belle
collection d'ailleurs ma vie avec
il s'agit de parler de d'un apprenti
sage de la façon dont un enfant
construit son identité au travers de ses
lectures y compris à l'extérieur de ses
repères de ces familiaux et comment se
tisse dans l'écriture telle que nous la
retrouvons aujourd'hui l'identité d'un
homme et l'identité et que nous
partageons ici mais justement à ce
stade-là Bernard cazen est-ce que c'est
pas inhabituel aujourd'hui pour un homme
politique
de se présenter j'allais dire avec un
blason littéraire je me souviens en tant
que journaliste politique qu'avec
certains hommes politiques qui avaient
de la culture je pense à Laurent Fabius
et Alain Juppé ils ont même essayé de
cacher un peu leur côté littéraire pour
faire peuple et vous vous essayez est-ce
qu'il y a pas un côté un peu rétro là de
d'apparaître aujourd'hui surtout dans le
climat social de la France avec ce
blason là mais pourquoi est-ce que vous
voulez que je me préoccupe de ces sujets
pourquoi est-ce que vous voulez que je
m'occupe lorsque j'ai quelque chose à
dire ou quelque chose à écrire de savoir
quel est l'air du temps pourquoi
faudrait-il toujours quand on exerce une
responsabilité publique ou qu'on en
donne à exercer une se poser la question
de savoir si ce que l'on va faire va
plaire ou déplaire en se privant de la
possibilité d'apparaître comme on est
profondément sincèrement je ne raisonne
pas de cette manière-là je fais ce que
j'estime devoir faire quand j'en ai
envie en fonction de ce que me dit que
ma conscience avec une liberté totale et
si ensuite les meute des réseaux sociaux
ou les commentaires
vont dans une direction ou plutôt que
dans une autre c'est l'affaire de ce qui
commence c'est pas la mienne je pense
que on doit quand même quand on est dans
la vie publique et qu'on a une parole
publique pouvoir de temps en temps
témoigner de son sa liberté et
s'affranchir de ce que sont les
contraintes de l'époque donc toutes les
questions que vous posez sont très
légitimes ce sont des questions de
journalistes bah oui mais vous avez
conscience qu'on ne va un peu à
contre-courant aujourd'hui de l'esprit
le nombre de ceux qui déploient une
énergie considérable pour être sûr
d'être dans le courant dominant pour
être dans la masse grégaire de ceux qui
vont toujours dans la même direction
avec pour ceux et unique obsession
d'augmenter leur nombre de followers
c'est pas mon préoccupation il y a
quelques années je faisais écrire
Marthe Robert la critique littéraire
dans une revue que je dirige et que je
dirige toujours qui s'appelle passage
dans une chronique qui s'appelait
chronique du présent obscur vous auriez
pu signer une chronique comme celle-là
qui à l'époque avait impressionné le
ministère de la Culture de
on considérant que aujourd'hui
tout ce qui est
instantané présent etc
occupe toute la scène et on manque de
recul en quelque sorte tu vois j'étais
très marquée par la lecture de cet
auteur comme la lecture de bien d'autres
auteurs
Tchekhov
Camus Balzac aurait pu écrire
d'autres livres et peut-être le frère
d'ailleurs dans les années qui viennent
et peut-être écrire et moi-même des des
ouvrages littéraires qui évoqueront la
mémoire d'aucun de ces personnes âgées
je le fais simplement sincérité et je le
fais parce que dans la période dans
laquelle nous vivons un homme qui
résiste à son époque qui se détache de
son milieu qui sait que l'époque dans
laquelle il vit est une époque où on
s'intéresse moins à ce que disent ce qui
s'exprime qu'à l'endroit où il parle
accepte de s'affranchir de toutes les
contraintes et les entraves de son
milieu pour qu'on l'écoute enfin pour
qu'on s'intéresse davantage à ce qu'il
dit qu'à l'endroit où il parle il fait
pour cela bien des choses courageux
qui le mettent en orthogonalité par
rapport à son milieu et je trouve ça
extrêmement courageux on pouvait
s'attendre à ce que Mauriac prit une
autre position sur l'affaire de la
guerre d'Espagne on aurait pu imaginer
qu'il aurait été davantage dans le
courant voracien que adhérents ou si on
ne marque Sonnier on aurait pu imaginer
que
tenir des propos beaucoup plus
à même vis-à-vis de l'Église catholique
et de son comportement notamment au
moment de l'affaire Dreyfus alors que sa
famille était totalement anti-dréfusarde
mais il y a un oncle qui est inspiré le
mystère Frontenac qui est le frère de
son père qui est un livre penseur son
père d'ailleurs à Mauriac était un livre
penser avec des packs catholiques tous
les vendredis il avait les mét une
côtelette devant son épouse pour bien
montrer que la distance qu'il avait avec
la religion donc cette c'est un homme
qui durant toute sa vie y compris en
restant fidèle à ses convictions
religieuses c'est-à-dire aux messages
universel du Christ prend à l'égard des
églises c'est à dire des institutions
qui verrouillent qui cadenas et des
observateurs
autoproclamés et qui dont le jugement
est toujours prompte et pas toujours
pertinent il prend à l'égard de tous ces
acteurs une liberté totale qui témoigne
d'une audace absolue et c'est pour
rendre hommage à cela que j'ai fait ce
livre ouais alors Raphaël gaillard
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cet
affranchissement j'allais dire Cazeneuve
vient si on peut dire par rapport au
temps à l'époque au personnage que sur
les temps présent je suis pas sûr d'être
compétent mais sur le sur la dynamique
d'un homme et vous avez fait référence
et à Marthe Robert et au roman familial
elle a beaucoup écrit sur cette question
du roman familial comme à l'origine du
roman origine du roman et roman des
origines et je trouve que c'est une idée
très intéressante qui part d'une
construction de la psychanalyse selon
laquelle l'enfant
à un moment donné de son développement
va sortir de l'horizon familiale pour
définir choisir des figures
d'identification au-delà y compris
d'ailleurs dans le fantasme qu'il puisse
être lui-même l'enfant d'un autre
enfant trouvé et enfin adopté
rejetons d'une autre famille etc et
cette dynamique du roman familial que
que tout enfant traverse elle trouve une
autre nature au moment de la lecture et
je trouve que c'est très intéressant je
suis pas sûr que même Marthe Robert qui
était très fine et beaucoup dit
dans ces années-clés c'est-à-dire dans
ces années dite de la période de latence
entre 8 et 12 ans on découvre la
littérature et où se dessine par la
littérature un intérêt qui sera marquant
sur toute l'existence et c'est cette
fois pas tant se penser
issue d'une autre filiation mais c'est
réellement s'inscrire dans une autre
filiation qui est l'affiliation
littéraire et je trouve passionnant de
voir chez tout un chacun la façon dont
la lecture à cet âge comme vous le
racontez à 9 ans devient déterminante
dans sur le cadre de pensée sur et pas
seulement le cadre de pensée sur le je
dirais presque la texture de la
personnalité
dans tout le devenir d'une personne mais
on le sent très bien c'est pour ça que
je pointais que c'est votre moriac parce
qu'on sent très bien comment se tisse
votre personnalité et cette lecture et
d'autres lectures parce que
effectivement on est en devine beaucoup
d'autres et qui je pense le cheminement
d'une personne donc sur les temps
présent je ne saurais pas dire mais je
pointe en psychiatre que cette dynamique
de la lecture et la façon dont elle
contribue à construire une personnalité
y compris en dehors de ces repères et
bien au-delà bien au-delà de ces repères
familiaux elle est constitutive et
extrêmement importante pour les
individus que nous sommes alors
juste un petit mot quelque chose que je
dois vous ce livre je l'ai écrit en même
temps c'est le mystère le hasard des
correspondances et des rencontres que
j'achechevais la lecture des deux tomes
sur la genèse d'andrégide de Jean de
lait et c'est-à-dire la construction de
de la personnalité d'andrégide dans
l'enfance raconté par le prédécesseur de
Raphaël gaillard dans Sainte Anne grand
psychiatre grand
érudit homme de lettres
et j'étais très frappé par les deux
tomes de la Genèse d'andrégide parce que
d'abord ceci comme un roman et ensuite
on voit très bien le processus que vous
venez de décrire très très cliniquement
presque de construction de la
personnalité à travers les épreuves et
les étapes de la jeunesse et
lorsque je me mets à faire ce livre sur
moreac pendant le confinement je viens
d'achever la lecture de ces deux tomes
de la jeunesse d'andrégide de Jean delay
j'étais très impressionné par la la
somme que constitue l'intensité de cette
somme que constitue ces deux tomes et
bien entendu ça éveille en moi beaucoup
de questionnements sur ce qu'est
l'enfance et la jeunesse dans le
processus de construction de chaque
individu à travers la rencontre avec la
nature les épreuves familiales les
drames que peuvent rencontrer les
familles en l'occurrence il perdra son
père aussi très très jeune oui comme
Mauriac et tous ces épreuves auront
contribué
façonner des personnalités
André Gide disait de François Mauriac
que sur la question de la chair il avait
beaucoup de chaînes il sur cette
question là et Mauriac disait JIDE
qu'ils avaient trop cassé les chaises
à la religion donc ils avaient quelques
contentieux là ils avaient quelques
contentieux mais il y a pas cette espèce
de transgression chez Mauriac on a
l'impression que il n'y va pas
clairement le Gide n'a pas par exemple
hésiter à
apparaître comme homosexuel tout en
étant un très grand écrivain c'est ce
qui n'a pas voulu François Mauriac oui
il n'a pas voulu apparaître ainsi
parce que le rapprochement
entre JD et Mauriac c'est aussi des mers
excessivement puritaines
café explosé Gide et que n'a pas fait
exploser Mauriac parce que Mauriac s'est
attaché
comme j'ai d'ailleurs comme réel avec le
même passion du réel et et de
la même acuité de romancier il l'a
appliqué aux hommes politiques et à son
analyse mais
c'est important ce que vous dites de la
jeunesse parce que mon père pensait que
la jeunesse et la genèse d'un écrivain
se constitue il joue bien sûr sur le mot
jeunesse jeunesse et alors et donc quand
Raphaël gaillard évoque le stade du
miroir ou l'enfant se
dédouble enfin
et que pour Bernard Cazin c'est le neude
vipère
on est quand même très très frappé alors
moi je voudrais vous interroger à tous
les trois sur l'enfant Cazeneuve
l'enfant de l'Est l'enfant gaillard sur
ce nœud familial parce que
il est François Mauriac est d'une
fidélité contrariée par rapport à sa
famille avec quelques silences sur son
histoire
tandis que on prend un grand écrivain
comme Thomas Bernard dans extinction il
considère qu'il faut mettre de côté sa
famille Annie Ernot dit qu'on écrit pour
venger sa race par rapport à cette
question des origines chacun de vous
vers la case neuve vous pensez qu'on
écrit pour venger sa race pour
l'éteindre pour la pour en prolonger
pour faire pourquoi finalement
dont je ne parviens pas à éclairer la
source
en tous les cas le sens qu'elle révèle
c'est que la mémoire des morts préside à
l'action des vivants
est-ce que j'ai trop de relations avec
des êtres que je n'ai jamais connu
et y compris de ma propre famille et
pour ne pas finalement me dire que
Mitterrand devait avoir raison lorsqu'il
disait croire aux forces de l'esprit
et donc moi j'ai écrit pour que les
films ne seront pas
pour que les fils d'une histoire
familiale qui vient de loin et qui
concerne beaucoup d'être qu'on n'a pas
connu et d'autres qui n'appartenaient
pas à la famille
au sens génétique du terme mais qui
peuvent appartenir à la famille pensée
ou la famille de connivence que ces
fils-là ne seront pas et donc ce qui me
surprend beaucoup et avec l'âge qui
avance de plus en plus c'est les
connexions les correspondances qui
peuvent se nouer à un moment ou à un
autre avec des personnages qu'on a
jamais rencontré qu'on ne rencontrera
jamais et dont on a pour par ailleurs
une connaissance intime et très
mystérieuse et parfois l'écriture permet
d'essayer un peu malgré soi ou en dépit
de soi-même de restituer ce que sont ces
fils et de comprendre comment ils se
sont constitués peu à peu malgré soi ou
en dépit de soi-même Florence là-dessus
parce que c'est écrire pour faire
revivre ses morts pour retrouver
je vais revenir à votre question
préalable sur l'enfance
j'ai eu une grande chance j'ai eu une
enfance heureuse
j'ai eu un père aimant
une mère etc qui était grand lecteur qui
avait des passions de lecture et ça
d'une certaine façon la
limocité du paysage littéraire
c'était la grandeur de l'appartement
familial la bibliothèque de chacun la
bibliothèque de ma mère la vision mon
père et je pense que j'ai vécu parmi les
livres comme parmi des plantes comme
parmi un jardin
donc j'ai tout de suite aimé
les livres et j'ai tout de suite
souhaité
faire et d'être écrit d'être écrivain
mais pas écrivain pour écrire et
écrivain de pas pour célébrer les morts
mais vous êtes le script des origines
pour célébrer
et je ne savais pas encore quoi célébrer
mon éducation d'abord et mon premier
livre a été un roman d'éducation qui
s'appelait minuit sur les jeux ou grâce
au bonheur qui fut le mien j'arrivais à
me moquer de moi-même et à décrire
l'éducation d'une chaîne bourgeoise et
d'ailleurs le livre s'appelait la
bourgeoise surnaturelle mais
Gallimard trouvait que ça ressemblait
trop à rêveuse bourgeoisie alors on m'a
obligé d'en changer Raphaël gaillard sur
ce thème là important
manger sa race j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
de tissage par la lecture et Bernard
Cazeneuve évoquait les fils qui ne
devraient pas se rompre et nous sommes
donc dans cette métaphore du tissage que
nous pourrions poursuivre par le
métissage qui se Nina mon ambivalence
quand elle se propose sur la race et la
vengeance je crois que
[Musique]
plutôt que
plutôt que cette violence
il est intéressant de voir comment
peuvent s'hybrider des univers
différents par l'écriture si c'est
l'écriture mais en amont de l'écriture
par la lecture parce que lire c'est déjà
d'une certaine façon écrire c'est c'est
déjà être dans un processus d'écriture
que d'être lecteur et ce chemin de la
lecture c'est pas du tout un chemin
neutre c'est pas un chemin
qui laisse de côté
ou en regard de son livre celui qui clôt
le livre c'est le lecteur et ce chemin
là alors effectivement il fait circuler
des générations différentes il tissent
des histoires différentes et il dessine
une identité et je trouve que ce
cheminement ces cheminement qui c'est
vrai suppose un temps long c'est vrai
elle suppose
un temps là sont extrêmement
intéressants pour comprendre la
complexité la richesse d'une
personnalité et dans mon métier de
psychiatre ce qui m'intéresse c'est
c'est la substance d'une personnalité
c'est le c'est l'étoffe d'une
personnalité c'est c'est tout toute la
complexité les faux semblants les clairs
obscures c'est pas la grande lumière
c'est pas
le blanc et le noir c'est quelque chose
qui procède du tissage qui je pense
bénéficie de cet apprentissage par la
lecture alors on parle beaucoup de
Montréal mais on a parlé aussi d'un
certain genre de lait alors Florence n'a
pas besoin
d'en parler si je puis dire puisque
c'est son père
Raphaël a pris la suite puisqu'il est
chef du pôle de psychiatrie à
Sainte-Anne ou Jean de Léa officier et
vous comment avez-vous trouvé qu'est-ce
qui vous a amené à lire Jean de lait qui
est d'abord un psychiatre même si
c'était un homme de littérature
ce qui m'aime déjà à dire Jean delay
c'est une insomnie en réalité parce
qu'il y a un soir où j'étais totalement
impossibilité de m'endormir je suis allé
sur le site de l'Institut national de
l'audiovisuel pour regarder une émission
littéraire et je vois un personnage
apparaître dans cette émission qui
raconte la jeunesse d'andrégide je suis
très impressionné par la qualité de
langue le niveau de précision du propos
et le sentiment de comment dirais-je
donc là c'est intellectuel qui se dégage
du personnage alors je vais sur le site
de Lina pour essayer de trouver d'autres
vidéos et là je trouve une longue
interview faite par un diplomate qui
avait de l'intérêt pour la littérature
monsieur leader de Jean delay
et je vois une conversation se nouée
entre
l'interviewer et l'écrivain ou
l'écrivain avec énormément d'humilité de
gentillesse parce qu'il y a une très
grande gentillesse qui se dégage de la
personnalité de gens de la
profonde altérité je dirais pour être
plus précis qui corrige la marge
l'interviewer lorsque sur une date et il
se trompe sur un événement il est
insuffisamment précis et je suis fasciné
par ce personnage qui est à la fois une
encyclopédie vivante un amoureux des
lettres
un extraordinaire conteur et donc je me
plonge dans ce ses écrits pour essayer
de comprendre qu'il est et à mesure que
j'avance dans la découverte du
personnage elle a faitscination augmente
c'est pour moi c'est l'un des
des grands personnages de du siècle
dernier un intellectuel complet qui
toucher à plusieurs disciplines et les
amétriser toutes
qui a été aussi un homme dans son siècle
puisque je crois qu'il a rencontré
beaucoup d'acteurs ne pas du pari de
l'époque il les a connus il les a aimé
il les a fréquenté et sans doute les
a-t-il aussi jugés mais avec ce
caractère que j'ai décrit qui était
plein de bienveillance et puis alors ce
que ce que je ressens chez lui aussi et
qui qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est c'est
l'extrême solitude et exigences dans le
travail c'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas
produire une telle œuvre dans une vie
sans avoir consacré toute sa vie à ce
beau travail et donc c'est c'est le
contraire d'un
affabulateur d'un prestidigitateur c'est
un homme d'une rigueur
intellectuelle d'une rigueur au travail
absolue donc j'ai énormément
d'admiration pour Jean delay je suis
extrêmement
émue de faire cette émission avec
Florence en Roger ou en Rossi d'émotion
quand on entend ça Florence delay et
j'ai j'étais au courant de la façon dont
Bernard Cazeneuve est tombé amoureux de
mon père
j'étais au cours et ce que je voulais
dire c'était
quelle merveille d'entendre les voix
de pouvoir avoir ce bonheur dans le
siècle où on est de découvrir par une
voix une oeuvre
mais les livres fermés
n'ont pas de voix dès qu'on les ouvre
ils ont une voix donc il joue ce rôle
aussi
vous entendez Corneille quand même quand
vous lisez
mais on sera jamais quelle est la voix
de crevée mais on l'entend c'est pas du
tout la voix de Racine
et c'est merveilleux de voir aussi dans
la dans la bibliothèque
finalement un orchestre
existence de temps de voix dont nous
allons aimer certaines
même chérir
et dont nous allons détester d'autres
et c'est très agréable détester aussi et
de se prononcer de façon un peu violente
et je crois que cette violence n'est pas
étrangère à aucun de nous trois
bien dissimulé parfois moi je suis une
extrême courtoisie en apparence
un mot là-dessus Raphaël gaillard sur
la mémoire de les moi je suis toujours
ému de d'entendre parler de Jean de lait
qui est une figure tutélaire pour
[Musique]
il fallait aller au-delà de cette
trouvaille et je trouve que cette
exigence dans le champ de la
psychopharmacologie ou dans la culture
que vous avez ok quant à la littérature
c'est quelque chose est évidemment
d'inspirant pour la psychiatrie
[Musique]
alors je voudrais vous rappeler cette
citation de François Mauriac
ce sang des communistes des nationaux
des chrétiens des juifs nous a tous
baptisé du même baptême dans le général
de Gaulle demeure au milieu de nous le
symbole vivant alors c'est quasiment une
déclaration
d'amour de quoi est le nom cette passion
gaulliste
et pourquoi si je voudrais vous poser
cette question à vous tous pourquoi en
sommes-nous si loin aujourd'hui avec
cette société fragmentée populiste
narcissique etc
Bernard
d'évoquer on comprend ce qui rattache
Mauriac au catholicisme c'est moi les
institutions et les églises que le
message universel du Christ c'est cela
que porte cette citation et d'ailleurs
simoriac prendra les positions qu'il
prendra à l'égard de son milieu à
l'égard des églises c'est précisément
parce que c'est pour lui le message
universel du Christ qu'il faut retenir
de l'adhésion à la chrétienté au
catholicisme son gaullisme il n'est pas
ce que l'on croit le gaulisme de Mauriac
n'est pas une inconditionnalité au
général de Gaulle il a rencontré très
peu le général de Gaulle et à chaque
fois qu'il a rencontré ça s'est pas très
bien passé il rencontre pour la première
fois
au moment de la Libération il est reçu
avec son fils je crois rue
Saint-Dominique le général de Gaulle ne
lui parle que des postes vacants à
l'Académie française et lui est dans la
mythification du héros de la France
libre il s'attend à évoqué avec lui la
grandeur de la France les projets
politiques de celui qui la libéré mais
non le général de Gaulle compte le
nombre de sièges vacants l'Académie
interroge Montréal sur le fait de savoir
si on peut voir pouvoir faire élire à
tel siège tel personnalité ou telle
autre et Mauriac est très déçu parce
qu'il a l'impression de rencontrer un
homme politique deuxième rencontre il va
avoir le général de Gaulle pour essayer
de sauver brasillac de de la peine
capitale il est contre la peine de mort
comme chrétien il considère que
brasillac qui l'a détesté insulté
injurier
est un auteur et que la peine de mort
est une monstruosité il va chez le
général de Gaulle essayer de sauverasia
il sort de l'entretien avec le général
de Gaulle en disant j'ai rencontré un
corps mort
rien laissé apparaît bon le général de
Gaulle fait le RPF Mauriac saga sur le
thème je pensais
à ce grand héros de la France Libre
voilà qui se met à faire des parties
comme les politiciens de la 4e il ne le
dit pas comme ça mais c'est ce que ça
signifie et donc Mauriac n'a pas eu du
tout la relation d'inconditionnalité
qu'on écrit au général il a une
admiration
littéraire et politique pour le
personnage
cette admiration elle résulte en grande
partie du regard féroce qu'il porte sur
le médiocrité du personnage de la des
personnages de la Quatrième République
Joseph Laniel présentait comme un
personnage dans lequel il y a du lingot
Bido accrochés gris du Quai d'Orsay donc
il y a trois personnages sous la
Quatrième République qui plaisent à
Mitterrand de Gaulle qui est hors
concours pour des raisons historiques
Mendès France
qui est l'homme de la décolonisation et
du courage et que Mauriac va soutenir
Aliexpress avec beaucoup de force et
Mitterrand parce qu'il y voit un
personnage totalement romanesque et
qu'il y a vraisemblablement chez
Mitterrand comme chez Mauriac
s'exprimer Mitterrand a été un peu
Bachar aussi avec Mauriac lorsqu'il
reprend la formule de Claudel évoquant
Mauriac et le qualifiant de
meilleur de nos écrivains régionalistes
qui n'était pas chez François mitter un
compliment mais les deux hommes se
respectaient et s'estimés et morillac
voit en Mitterrand en de Gaulle et en
mandates pour des raisons différentes
des personnalités éminentes de la
Quatrième République parce que elles
sont intrinsèquement imminentes et parce
que tous les autres sont des médiocres
et que Mauriac a bien identifié et avec
la pointe qui caractérise son écriture
dans le bloc-notes il administre une
ordonnance à chacun de ceux dont il
considère et qui ne sont pas la hauteur
de la situation alors vous n'êtes pas
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous inspire
Raphaël gaillard
nous parlions de filiation de beaucoup
parler de filiation celle que celle que
nous nous imaginons nous ne pouvons nous
construire
l'affiliation bien réelle de Florence
delay
et puis apparaît une autre figure à
laquelle sera attachée en filiation
de Gaulle et je crois qu'il est toujours
question de la même chose c'est-à-dire
de de définir
déjà le nom
qui
donne une forme de temps long ou en tout
cas de perspective
qui ne sont pas les soubresauts de
l'Histoire et
vous indiquez que
Mauriac pouvait par un moment
resser dites-vous Mitterrand
quand tu as de Gaulle il y a une sorte
de
fidélité et de constance
dans le lien
qui procède je crois de cette idée qu'il
y a des
il y a des choses qui ne varient pas il
y a des choses qui tiennent alors vous
posez la question de des temps qui
courent comment fonctionner aujourd'hui
sans ce type de figure tutélaire sans ce
type de temps long sans cette sans cette
possibilité d'inscrire et même sans
cette unité nationale de prônée par
Mauriac et on ne sait pas ce qui est la
cause et la conséquence oui mais on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les choses
sont ébréchées de tous les côtés
ou pire encore qui est attendu un homme
providentiel et que c'est un
providentiel
rassemblerait autour d'un repli plutôt
que de l'histoire qui pourrait nous
réunir qu'est-ce que vous pensez
Florence de l'île de sarde
aujourd'hui et
profil bas effectivement
ces profils bas mais je crois qu'il faut
pas se cantonner là parce que
on finira par répéter tout le temps la
même chose à savoir qu'on traverse une
période sinistre bon mais la lumière
existe tous les jours il est possible
que tout ça se relève
bon je voudrais dire deux choses 1 que
si de Gaulle et un modèle c'est parce
que il a du courage bon il a eu du
courage dans une période bon et le
courage Mauriac admire bon faut pas
oublier
chez moriac
la charité
d'ailleurs Cazeneuve insiste là-dessus
justice et Charité on pourrait dire oui
mais alors pourquoi si méchant il est
méchant par justice
et au nom de la vérité
et je trouve formidable
qu'un écrivain un homme qui a commencé
vraiment à droite
ce reversent vers les idées dites de
gauche
à cause à cause de quoi et bien ce qui a
été vraiment vital pour lui c'est
l'attitude
médiocre lamentable du clergé espagnol
quand il a vu comment se conduisait
l'église en Espagne par rapport aux
républicains
et c'est formidable parce que là il le
vrai chrétien
dont on parlait bon maintenant pour
aujourd'hui
un redressons-nous tous
commençons par nous-mêmes
on est sur un point essentiel et
d'ailleurs dans votre livre vous le
dites il ne s'est trompé sur presque
rien or aujourd'hui si vous prenez les
grands écrivains les grands médecins les
grands ingénieurs les grands architectes
etc c'est des prises de position
successives et il n'y a pas si je puis
dire cette cette liberté cette à quoi
c'est dû à la médiocrité de la politique
et est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
pensez que vous pouvez y remédier avec
ce que vous souhaitez incarner
aujourd'hui pour la nation non mais
d'abord moi je pense pas du tout que
nous soyons sans écrivains sans
intellectuel sans ma panique non mais
qui porte même des portes
des idées courageuses qui les
manifestent qui les matérialise et pour
lesquels ils se mobilisent grandement
le problème est moins parmi les
intellectuels que parmi les politiques
et un peu aussi la classe médiatique
si vous voulez quand les choses vont mal
que quand vous vivez une période
d'affaissement des institutions de sens
des repères du sens de l'État et du sens
de la nation trouver dans le pays le
ressort du sursaut ou du redressement il
faut que c'est que ceux qui portent une
parole publique est d'abord une
conviction et une seule qu'avait le
général de Gaulle et qui avait aussi des
personnalités comme Pierre Mendès France
c'est l'idée que la France est plus
grande que
ils ont été animés tout au long de leur
vie par une idée simple c'est que la
France était infiniment plus grande qui
ne l'était de même et que dès lors qu'il
décidait de la servir il pouvait la
servir que dans la plus grande
abnégation donc ça donne le départ du
général de Gaulle avec son aide de camp
sans sa famille à Londres sans savoir ce
dont ce mas sera fait et sans savoir si
cet acte d'ailleurs pour lui ne signifie
pas jusqu'à la renonciation de de
pouvoir continuer à vivre libre mais il
pose cet acte parce que il pense à un
moment donné que la France est plus
grande que lui et que se mettre au
service de ce pays alors même qu'il a
une certaine idée de lui-même implique
la plus grande abnégation et non pas la
recherche d'une position d'un avantage
d'une lumière d'une gratification d'un
honneur
mais la recherche de l'accomplissement
du devoir parce que il n'y a pas
d'autres choix que d'accomplir son
devoir c'est ce que fait Pierre Mendès
France lorsqu'il décide de partir
quelques semaines en se fixant lui-même
devant leur présentation nationale
l'obligation de revenir en France après
avoir réglé le problème de l'Indochine
c'est ce que le général de Gaulle se
fixe pour agenda lui-même lorsqu'il
décide d'engager la France sur le chemin
enfin la résistance et la franchise sur
le chemin de la résistance à tout prix
en prenant tous les risques elle
occupant donc pour moi la solution elle
est dans la capacité de chacun d'entre
nous quel que soit son destin de ce
convaincre que la France est plus grande
que lui et d'y consacré la part
d'énergie qu'il peut y consacrer pour
faire en sorte que la France continue
générale de quoi avait une très belle
formule qui devrait faire réfléchir tous
ceux qui parfois s'aller et la facilité
de l'ostracisation de l'autre ou de la
xénophobie de Gaulle disait et français
celui qui veut que la France continue
et français celui qui veut que la France
continue
et donc tous ceux qui veulent que la
France continue avec ces traverses son
histoire sa capacité d'épopée et qui
sont convaincus qu'il faut que la France
continue parce qu'elle est plus grande
que nos vies et que chacune et chacun
d'entre nous doivent consacrer l'énergie
qui doit l'être à son redressement
comment vous ressentez Saint-Raphaël
gaillard la France est plus grande
est-ce que le matin avant de vous raser
vous vous dites la France est plus
grande que moi
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a quelque
chose qui vient
oui c'est tendancieux comme question
peut-elle tendancieuse
je trouve que je trouve que ça élargit
la perspective et dans les mots que vous
utilisez Bernard Cazeneuve
il est question de ce qui est plus grand
que nous en l'occurrence la France et
donc d'un destin collectif
mais il est aussi question de la façon
dont il s'écrit dont il peut continuer
et vous dites épopée et je crois que la
trame est toujours la même en fait notre
âme est celle de l'écriture la lecture
l'écriture et cette continuité là cette
fois vous vous l'exprimer non à
l'échelle individuelle celle qui vous a
forgé de jeunes lecteurs et de l'homme
Bernard Cazeneuve que vous êtes devenu
mais de cette nation en tout cas de
cette communauté qui qui vit d'histoire
et qui a tout avantage à pouvoir en
raconter et pouvoir en écrire d'autres
et je pense que c'est très important de
pouvoir penser les choses au delà de
l'homme providentiel d'ailleurs c'est
aussi intéressant que nous ne parlions
pas que de Gaulle mais aussi demandé ce
France
trop souvent éclipsé y compris dans
notre échange
je pense que au-delà de l'homme
providentiel au-delà de la figure
tutélaire celle-ci pour pour la nation
le De Gaulle il est question de cette
écriture commune qui qui définit une
trajectoire une histoire et qui est une
histoire dynamique qui est une histoire
qui qui doit continuer pour reprendre le
mot de De Gaulle et à laquelle nous nous
employons donc et pas seulement avant de
se raser chacun
envie de vous poser une question que
tout le monde se pose
et s'interroge puisque
un climat un peu fiévreux en France
aujourd'hui la politique est très
décriée ont vécu une très longue crise
sociale etc finalement qu'est-ce que
vous apportez et qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez apporter
à cette France
dont vous venez de parler et à laquelle
vous voulez restituer à la fois une
grandeur une noblesse une solidarité etc
mais fais moi je suis
1.65 millionième de la France mais pas
comme ça vous avez politique
certainement mais si l'on veut partager
l'idée avec le plus grand nombre de nos
concitoyens que la France est plus
grande que chacune et chacun d'entre
nous il faut commencer à restituer le
sens de l'action collective parce que la
politique est devenue un exercice
narcissant
individualiste et qui consiste pour ceux
qui s'illivent trop souvent
à construire un parcours pour eux-mêmes
sans se préoccuper de ce qu'est le sens
de la nation donc si on veut être utile
aujourd'hui il faut contribuer par
l'élaboration d'un projet par
l'organisation d'une force politique par
le retour du sens de l'action collective
il faut contribuer à donner une
perspective au pays le premier sujet
c'est celui de des valeurs et des
principes et notamment des valeurs et
des principes républicains
lorsque je vois qu'il y a des forces
politiques qui expliquent que les
institutions de la République sont
tournés contre les citoyens et qui est
ces engendrer au cœur du pays un
sentiment de relégation et de colère à
l'égard des institutions de la
République c'est la police tu
sont ces propos qui sont diffusés à
l'encontre de ceux qui représentent les
institutions et qui sont
systématiquement présentés comme étant
les artisans d'un complot ou du
stérilité à l'égard de leur propre
peuples je me dis que on est loin des
principes républicains de la promesse
républicaine
d'institutions qui sont là pour lutter
contre la discrimination contre la
relégation contre toutes les formes de
d'injustice bon la laïcité n'est pas un
principe que l'on négocie
l'altérité n'est pas un sujet sur lequel
on tergiverse et le respect de l'autre
qui ne pense pas comme soi devrait être
une exigence absolue portée par chacun
plutôt que de provoquer systématiquement
l'ex-communication l'insulte l'injure en
créant les conditions d'une mise sous
tension du pays ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est qu'il faut
réconcilier la justice sociale avec
l'efficacité économique troisième défi
c'est le défi écologique nous nous
sommes battus beaucoup d'entre nous pour
que la vie soit meilleure moi mes
enfants se battent pour que la vie soit
possible ils ont 25-26 ans c'est
celle-là leur combat et donc comme il se
battent pour que la vie soit possible il
leur arrive d'être
en adhésion avec les thèses les plus
radicales et si on donne pas un débouché
politique à la radicalité nous aurons
l'extrémisme et le quatrième grand sujet
c'est le multilatéralisme l'Europe et la
paix
et dans le multi latéralisme l'Europe et
la paix et à l'universalisme et à la
défense des langues qui portent
l'université il y a tous ces grands
sujets qui sont des sujets qui renvoient
à l'histoire à la grandeur aux valeurs à
l'âme et
la culture des peuples beaucoup de
choses à dire merci Bernard cazen merci
Florence delay merci Raphaël gaillard
alors je voudrais rappeler une brève
bibliographie alors de Jean-Luc Barret
biographie intime de Jean la couture
c'est des classiques à laquelle assez
classique s'ajoute le dernier ouvrage de
Bernard Cazeneuve ma vie avec Mauriac
Florence delay je rappelle que vous avez
écrit il n'y a pas de cheval sur le
chemin de Damas c'était vos derniers
livres je crois où je suis en retard
avant dernier et le dernier c'est zigzag
zigzag voilà donc
zigzag Rafael gaillard nous avons déjà
eu l'occasion de parler de le coup de
hache dans la tête donc vous avez publié
également chez Gallimard je voudrais bon
donc encore vous renouveler mes
remerciements pour cette émission
extrêmement intéressante à laquelle
j'espère nous aurons l'occasion aussi
d'apporter des prolongements je voudrais
remercier l'équipe de LCP avant de nous
quitter je vous laisse avec
cette citation
concernant Mauriac il avait su rester un
homme libre il savait prendre parti avec
fracas c'est curieux un catholique qui
avait le sens de l'humour d'après vous
c'est de qui
écoutez c'est un acteur célèbre
puisqu'on vous dit qu'on fait parler les
morts Michel Simon
[Musique]